oh right let's do this one last time my
name is Conan Denis O'Brien when I was
15 years old I was bitten by a
radioactive party clown at my
quinceanera
you probably know the rest with no
talent comes no responsibility dad
how does that help me it doesn't too
late old man that furro clown gave me
powers beyond my wildest dreams which
made me very popular in high school and
popular with the ladies I even met my
first love now I could have used my
powers to fight crime battle evil and
rescue innocent people but instead I
opted for cheap laughs and light
celebrity chat you're afraid of heights
yes this is true what's true hmm I even
met my best friend Andy I'm so sick of
your voice
yep the Conan Empire is alive and well I
have a hit podcast a serial a line of
toys a sex column in southwest airlines
magazine an erectile dysfunction
medication and was recently named the
face of skin cancer awareness in
Malaysia and now I've returned to San
Diego comic-con for the fifth time I'm
like the cool high school student who
graduates and comes back to hang out the
next year
everybody loves that guy hey are you Amy
Adams no I am comic-con and comic-con is
me step down from the mailbox miss Adams
[Music]